this week we're talking about how amazon
could bring back stargate really really
easily how either a hard reboot or a
continuation could work what storylines
might we see
what will fans really love and what will
fans really really hate welcome to
scitrek your sci-fi tv and movie channel
[Music]
hello everybody i'm going to be arguing
today that a hard reboot might not
actually be that bad
it's not the ideal situation i will
admit it's something i don't personally
want myself but hey we're here and i'm
going to argue
that it might not be as bad so let's
discuss
hard reboots
no no hard reboot i know i know no hard
reboot jay you keep telling me this
but what if yes hard reboot a franchise
that's been pretty much dead in the
water since sgu left our screens in 2011
a hard reboot might not be as bad as the
alternative which is no stargate at all
no
hard
reboot okay well let's just discuss a
few reasons why a hard reboot might
actually be a good idea why it might
make sense for amazon to look at it on
paper and say yes let's hard reboot this
property because you know we can't
continue this stargate sg1 stargate
atlantis target sgu in total with all
the movies combined they ran for a total
of 17 seasons and three movies a lot
happened within that time frame we saw
the rise and the fall of the guar wall
the rise and the fall of the replicators
in the fall of the alright and we even
saw the jafar become the free jafar
nation rising up from their shackles of
slavery for the gold world that they
have been imprisoned in for thousands
and thousands of years they are now a
free race we met the asgard we saw them
die we met the knox the tollen we
discovered atlantis and woke up the
wraith and even unlocked the final ninth
chevron of the stargate and sent a team
to destiny and within all of that time
we developed so much technology we got
our own ships we improved our weapons we
built alliances across the galaxy in
fact across two galaxies and the towery
really laid their foundation as being
one of the top players in the galaxy but
where do you go from there with
everything that's gone on in the past
i'm finding it difficult to envision a
storyline that's going to be an adequate
threat that's going to be on par with
the global the replicators or the aura
because we're just so powerful no hard
reboot yeah but what
reboot okay but but no hydra boot no my
dream what the [ __ ] no i had reboot no
dream boot no my dream boot jay
just listen
with a hard reboot they could revitalize
the series they could bring back old
stories and give them a fresh new twist
king harter new start we can see
reimaginings of characters that we love
the asgard how to reboot
the gu old we could see the ascended
engines and actually see the ascended
higher plane no hard reboot in spanishes
there could be new enemies that are much
more powerful than the grow old much
more powerful than the replicators we
could have new fresh ship designs
new planets to explore we could go to
different galaxies you still don't seem
to be getting this so how about no hard
rebooting russian
it's not ideal i know
i don't want a hard reboot i would
absolutely love a continuation but what
if we do get one
we just have to look at it as a positive
because any stargate is good
i would love stargate to come back
if it's a hard reboot i'm still going to
watch it because it's stargate and if
it's a continuation i'll be super happy
but what do you guys think you've heard
my case you've heard what i've had to
say and on thursday you'll hear jay talk
about why he thinks the continuation
would be way better i'll see things and
spoiler alert i'm going to be agreeing
with everything jay says because i found
this video really hard i was tasked to
argue that a hard reboot would be good
and
as a fan who wants a continuation it's
hard to argue that a hard reboot would
be good
but hopefully
even if we do get a hard reboot i've
persuaded you enough that you will
actually watch the show and support it
because having stargate on our screens
is better than not having stargate on
our screens if you are new to the
youtube channel please hit subscribe and
press the bell notifications so you
don't miss a single video whilst you're
down there consider becoming a fully
fledged side tracker as well hit the
join button down below you can also buy
sidetrack merch at
scitrek.com some awesome mugs some
awesome t-shirts things like that link
for that will be in the description
thank you so much for watching look out
for jay's video on thursday and i will
see you next week
[Music]
you